do you get free next tickets now
huh Nick saying never give me not one
ticket bro really not one ticket [__]
the New York Knicks no you gave them a
whole remix oh I gave them a remix
[__] rally and cry bro what he did
not do the right thing at all at all
wait it didn't even offer oh matter of
fact they didn't reach out I went I did
this they reached out for me to do their
celebrity game I did it and it was like
yo whatever whatever game you want just
let us know I just said I like towards
the end of last season I was like all
right let me redeem these tickets like
give me a I don't care what's the game
snakes don't don't disrespect me and
give me some bullshits I need Courtside
or I'm not going yeah every time my Nick
hits a [__] three bing bong bing bro
they never got back well they tried to
hit me with the [__] seat so it had
me try to do some content for them yo
give me these [__] seats I ain't
doing [__] like [__] out of here man hmm
they've been disrespecting me for Mad
Seasons I'm a life I was a lifelong Nick
fan but not no more when I see how they
do business that [__] is disgusting at
least you guys have Brunson that's nice
I don't give a [__] who we got yeah [__]
them
[__] them
go Nets facts I mean Brooklyn no [__]
sixes go [__] sons who gives a [__] I
like that all I care about is the Giants
New York football Giants bro smack the
[__] out the Cardinals do you like
Daniel Jones no I'm doing he had a good
year bro he beat the Vikings in the
playoffs yeah yeah he's growing on me
pause yeah and I think Barkley's out of
there though I think he was not he's bad
he probably does but he's he's here he's
back he's one year [__] contract yeah
yeah [__] idiots yeah if Daniel Jones
is 70 million whatever seven year
contract to give saquan no [__] I
just don't feel like you should ever
give anyone who played football for Duke
yeah that much money like you played
football at Duke yo gotta be some racial
[__] bro these they be always they
always get white quarterbacks I mean
also they're [__] over these running
backs like Dalvin cook they [__] he's
on the Jets what the [__] yo the Jets on
the low got a squad they got [__]
they're gonna be nice what's his name
Sauce Gardener no Aaron Rodgers and
Rogers bro
but the Jets always do that they always
pick up a dope ass quarterback after his
prom yeah that's just picking up a check
is it like a a tense rivalry between the
Giants and jets yeah I mean the Jets are
funny because they they're terrible yeah
I mean they're like the Mets you know
I'm saying it takes a lot of heart to be
a fan to be to be Jets or Mets fans
because you know they're not winning no
time soon it's like the time Rogers with
[__] who was the um the cornerback
they got a couple years ago Rivas Rivas
they don't do nothing with these [__]
stars at the end of the day like if
you're a Jets Mets fan you probably
would forgive your wife for [__]
another man absolutely you would
probably walked in your wife again and
you'd be and you know what you do you'd
be like I've dealt with my whole life
hey hey guess what I'm mad right now
maybe next year but I'm gonna go walk it
off all right when I come back these
guys better not be here and my dinner
better be ready at least take a shower
before bed
go Mets
come
yo so the album is out man everybody
should go support rise of the Silverback
is out right now wherever you listen to
music if you [__] watch this whole
[__] and you don't go listen to the
[__] album
Bro [__] Your Life [__] choke on a
dildo what's your
glass or rubber glass go break it two
front teeth yeah you know some [__]
have put a glass dildo in like a freezer
that's some [__] horseshit
gotta be a hole to do that like I
remember like when I was like 19 I
opened this bitch's freezer I was at her
crib in the middle of the night I opened
her freezer and there was a [__]
dildo in there and I was like
it feels good like when you when you
freeze the glass dildo I'm like
that's like the glass the kids in the
Christmas story when he puts his tongue
up won't that happen to the [__] yeah
right that's a good point
wow it's my new [__]
that'd be [__] up bro you'd have a
real uh that'd be a painful
penetration hey yo all right bro what we
getting that Rise of the Silver back out
now bro
where can people buy the merch fyl dot
NYC there's no.com people get confused
like oh there's no.net.com no it's
www.fyl dot NYC and if you're in New
York come by the fyl store and if well
go buy [__] Zoomies go to Zoomies go
to uh Coney Island get you a Glizzy and
go to the store bags there it is man I
appreciate you pulling up brother always
I always nibs